breathing is one of those things we're
always doing it how you do it matters
all right what's the favor saying how
you do one thing is how you do
everything
how do you breathe because that's what
you're doing the most of you're not
doing any one activity more than that
where are you practicing your yoga in
changu
where am i where are you practicing it
in changi are you going to a studio
oh you look right behind me like right
there that
that little space behind me on that
floor that's uh
that's where i practice you okay so
you're not going to obviously there's a
lot of different yoga studios out there
nice places with bamboo leaves and
everyone in lululemon and you're not
bothering to
venture there's some beautiful studios
here
on saturdays i go to kirtan which is
like um
yoga music so basically people get
together
and someone plays harmonium and someone
plays a drum or something and you sing
mantras and kirtans yeah
it's a i don't know it's it's kind of a
it's called bhakti yoga bhakti means the
yoga of devotion
and so it's a different different sector
different aspect it's uh
it's good though yeah
i didn't realize until reading your book
that there was a philosophy behind yoga
i knew that it was
to do with embodied practice
and different levels of awakening and
stuff like that but i didn't realize
that there was a full philosophy behind
it
can you tell us a bit about that the
full philosophy about
of yoga there's there's a lot of
philosophy
in yoga and it really depends on what
what you're
talking about i think i think what most
people are familiar with as far as like
the
fundamental philosophy of yoga would be
the yoga sutras and patanjali's eight
limbs
which is essentially like the path of
yoga towards
enlightenment uh yeah there's
there's a lot of different ways you
could look at it or in
interpret it and i think
just like religion people take the text
and they kind of interpret it to
make sense of their lives and yoga
philosophy is really
really kind of the same way but it's
it's a guide just basically to
understand your life and how to live a
more harmonious life like any philosophy
is and i think that's really one of the
big differences
with with yoga compared to other kinds
of fitness
i mean yoga is yoga is an interesting
word in and of itself
because like all words we give words
meaning and
we define them to be what it is and so
uh like i know when i came into yoga
my definition for the word yoga was very
different than what it is now
it was it was like what i think the the
vast majority of people think of yoga
it's
stretching and sun salutations or maybe
ashtango or some sort of like physical
calisthenics type movement and that is
that is definitely what yoga is but it's
it's also
it's also like the way that you interact
the way that you think the way that you
breathe
there's the way that you conduct
yourself um
[Music]
i don't know for for me like it's this
it's the word that encompasses
understanding your fundamental truth
which i'm not going to tell you what
your fundamental truth is everyone's is
it's like that's that's the journey it's
like understanding that
in in of itself and we're all living
a subjective experience we all see the
world through our eyes
and i know for a long time i thought i
thought the world
like kind of uh revolved around me right
it's like
you you become self-centered and not
even in a negative way it's just you are
the center of yourself and
and and that's how you see things
uh and i think as you become more
mindful and more aware
of of reality or the truth of reality
you see that your perspective is
is simply that it's your perspective and
no one else shares your perspective
and therefore you can't understand
anyone else's perspective
because you can only understand their
perspective from your space
yeah and and yoga shows you kind of
where you fit into that whole
and not being separate but more of being
a part of it
right and i think i have one of my my
favorite teachers his name is shiva das
he talks about what what the true
meaning of yoga is and it's uh
you know it's not about trying to be
happy or be fit or anything or
or even like uh or freedom from
suffering but it's
returning back to the truth and the
truth is that we're whole
and so uh that that's kind of like when
i think of yoga that's
that's what i think of and when i
practice yoga like i
i use the common vernacular that
everyone uses like yeah
are you going to go to yoga and i know
what they mean is are you going to go do
asana
and which is fine right yeah because yes
i'm that is a part of it that is
definitely part of it so i'm going to go
practice asana
but uh yeah it's definitely the
definition for it has changed and
and that's kind of just like the start
of the philosophy i mean we could spend
the whole time
talking about different aspects of
philosophy of yoga we could talk about
maya
how we see everything as illusion we
could talk about the yamas and the
niyamas and
and conducts with yourself and we can
talk about what enlightenment is and
spirituality and all that
but i think i think at the end of the
day everybody is going to find
what those words mean to them and define
those words
and give those those things significance
and essentially that's what all
philosophy is
it's finding the significance
do you think that a lot of people who
are practicing yoga are missing out on
that side i've been to a number of
yoga practices some where you are in
changu
and also local ones in the uk and
although
there is a talk of something broader
than the movements themselves
kind of on the surface connect to the
breath connect to your
self like you know the meditative
practice sort of words
doesn't ever really seem to leave the
mat
yeah i mean that's i i don't want to
really make that judgment
towards anyone else for their journey
because there are definitely some people
that
it what's important is that whatever
you're doing you're getting something
from it
and you're going to take what you need
at that time
for me i ended up taking a lot more of
the
the philosophical part or the the
quote-unquote spiritual part
from yoga because that's what i needed i
was i was so lost
in my life i was um
i i am and always have been kind of uh
an adrenaline junkie or whatever like i
if there
i love to surf rock climb i was into
skydiving i'd i've
uh you know snowboarding whatever it was
like fun
and fast i enjoyed but i did it
not i did it because i loved it but
there's also like there's something
that i realized was missing in my life
or i didn't know was missing in my life
but i was getting it through those
things and it was
something that was as simple as being
present and we talk about this all the
time in yoga
and even like as yoga is now the the
philosophy yoga is seeping out into
into other you know i know you you do a
lot of the biohacking stuff and you're
into that
and this mindfulness and meditation and
that that really
has strong roots in yoga but not only in
yoga
so we see these these things all
starting to interconnect and seep into
each other
but i needed i needed to figure out what
it was to be here
and i didn't know i needed that all i
knew was that i thought my
life would be better in the future or
the past
and and for me it was generally the
future there's kind of
just there's not like to kind of put
people into like a general
place like there's some people
especially older people they
they reminisce of the past and so they
tend to live in the past
and if they're older there's more past
for them than there is future
right so they tend to be there if you're
a little bit younger
you might live more in the future
because you
your aspects and your goals and the the
prospect
of of your life being better lives in
the future and so you miss out what it
is to actually
live
and doing those extreme things i was
for the first time living and i was
first time being like the
ev the in yoga i talk about this almost
every podcast because i think it's such
such an important thing but the word sat
the the truth
um which means like unchanging right
everything in the world
is changing everything in the universe
is continuously changing there's
actually
an epic youtube video that shows the
the history of the universe and it goes
into trillions and trillions and
trillions of years and it's and it's
done to this like cool thing but it
it shows basically the end of all things
when
all the finals the final star burns out
because
that that's a crazy thing to think about
at one point
in the future the last sun will use
up all of its energy and there will be
no light in existence
and so if we could you know like the the
whole universe will
cease and then and then there will be
the cooling and everything will come to
absolute zero and then there'll be no
movement and then time
becomes completely irrelevant right
there's there's going to be a point
where time no longer exists because
there's nothing moving for time there's
nothing to experience it
so uh i know we're getting kind of way
off into a tangent here but
there there's one thing that at least we
could experience
now because because to live is to
experience and that's what life is
death is not experience that it's the
only thing that separates those two
we know we know what experience is so we
so we uh we tend to try to hold
on to that and we we're afraid of the
non-experience because we don't
understand that even though you can't
experience non-experience
it's just it's just there but the truth
the unchanging truth
is this present moment it's the window
that
that looks out into the changing world
that never changes itself
it's like sitting on a train and you and
that and you're just going down and you
look and you see
everything pass while everything passes
through that window and it's essentially
what your life is
and if you uh you know if you
if you turn your head then then you miss
actually what's going on
so i don't know yeah that's
as far as people getting there i didn't
think i would get there i got there
because i needed to get there
and i think the more people that
practice it practice yoga because yoga
is really
like that whole like focusing on the
breath and the body
and the thoughts that's all that is is
connecting those things together we're
used to living in this world where
where the mind and the body are two
different things and we think that
they're separate
and we think because i'm the one looking
because i'm i'm from my point of view
that everything else is not me
and and that's just the perspective of
things it's like the tree
the the leaves on a tree thinking that
they're not the tree
and so yeah i don't even know where i'm
going with this
but um
yeah so so we're in yoga we come into
that class and we and we start to
move into our body we start to actually
move into our breath a little bit deeper
and just
and where we start to understand a
little bit more of what
being means because all that all that
meaning comes from intention
and that was the real difference from
coming into yoga and doing extreme
sports
like in the street of sports i i was
brought to the present moment but
without intention and because i didn't
have the intention i didn't last
very long with yoga was it wasn't the
fact that i was practicing
practicing yoga but it was the fact that
there was an intention placed upon that
and that could be a definition of yoga
if you do anything with
intention that could be yoga i don't
know i think it's more helpful
to find the things that yoga is than to
try to find the things that yoga
isn't there's i've spent too much time
trying to defend what yoga is when it
needs
no defense and
and if if people listening if you're out
there trying to
find out what yoga isn't it's not gonna
help you in your journey towards
anything
yeah my thoughts i don't know i had this
conversation with paul bloom who is a
psychologist and philosopher from yale i
think
and uh he quoted this dominatrix
talking about why people are into bdsm
and hardcore sex
and he uh arrived at it in the same way
as why people do
extreme sports and why people do scary
things this quote from this dominatrix
is nothing captures attention like a
whip
and the point is that if someone slaps
you in the face really really hard
for one to five seconds after that
you're not thinking of
anything the mind is completely blank
but you are there you are in the moment
i think that the people that chase
extreme sport are looking for that same
presence you can't if you're base
jumping or snowboarding or
rock climbing and you do allow the mind
to
drift the implications are incredibly
grave
you might die yeah they can be and i i
could take that to kind of play a little
to maybe devil's advocate or or i
completely agree with that
uh but if that person continues to slap
you in the face for the next like
12 hours at some point in time
you're going to start thinking about
something else or you're going to try to
disassociate with that experience
you know so it's you could only it
outside outside stimula stimuli whatever
they are that it's eventually and that's
what i noticed with uh
with skydiving that after
after a certain number of jumps that i
was thinking about the next jump
rather than enjoying the jump that i was
on you know and so
is that part of the
usefulness of yoga that you are always
in control that you do have to have this
intentionality
that you are going into it and that
whatever happens is down to you whatever
doesn't happen is down to you there
aren't
any other than gravity there aren't
really very many external stimulus
that are acting on you is that why it's
forcing you to connect that
mind-body breath
i want to say i don't know
i mean that that's a that's a really
good question to kind of explore into
um i i just i think it's kind of
different for everybody
you've been working on the breath a lot
recently though how come you decided to
focus so much on that and a little bit
less on yoga when writing a book
it's not that it's something that was
the recent i think
i think people when they when they see
me or the people that follow me
and in my practice they really just see
the physical side
of it because that's the easiest thing
to show and
if
i i do like to write a lot and i and
since i started
my social media a big part of
of what goes into my post is is writing
about philosophy or writing about the
thoughts even if it's just like a simple
line or something trying to provoke
some sort of thought into someone else
so that maybe start a conversation or
start a con
that person starts a conversation with
themselves or someone else but
always in my practice since i started
yoga was
a breathing aspect i've learned
pranayama
from it and i talk about this in my book
in the beginning of the book of like
of coming into pranayama and really not
understanding what it was for other than
i was supposed to do it
right and i think a lot of people that
practice breath work
they just know that they're supposed to
do it and we know that we're supposed to
breathe
we have to we have no choice and people
that
start people are more into like the
biohacking stuff people that are taping
their mouth at night because they know
i'm supposed to breathe through my nose
and and i'm supposed to breathe less
like they they get that part of it but
there is a
a much greater aspect to the practice
other than just
breathing right or breathing less and
that is that everything
energetically physically emotionally
is linked to the breath and because it's
linked to the breath the breath has some
control over it and so essentially that
you could control almost every aspect of
your life
by learning how to control the breath
how the breath works
and you could what i do
mostly in my breath practice and this is
something that i think um
maybe for just the past six or seven
months or so
my my breath practices focus almost
entirely on increasing athletic
performance
and though you could do it for
everything and sometimes i do other
practices and stuff
but it's it's a tool it's a tool so you
you pick the tool that you need and you
figure out
what that tool does and how to use it
and how to
benefit and benefit your life with it
uh yeah so i've been i've i've been
doing breathing and studying breathing
and i've been teaching it
i've been teaching workshops and
seminars on breath work
[Music]
i want to say for like seven or eight
years i've been doing
doing those where i actually get quite
deep into the philosophy and all that uh
i yeah so it's always been a part of my
practice
i i had no intention really of writing a
book on
my first book anyways to be about
breathing
i was in i was here in bali last year
right before i flew
to london and my publisher
reached out to me and it's really kind
of like a serendipitous kind of thing
because
it was actually his wife that contacted
me first
him or her and the the owner of um
of the publishing house victory belt
publishing
they had been practicing with me online
for a good period of time and uh
the the owner of victory belt said that
he started yoga through my classes and
just
talked to him it kind of felt right and
i felt like he understood me a little
bit like knew me a little bit
and because i honestly didn't think i
could write a book
i was like there's there's no way that i
that i can do this and if i
did i thought my first book would be
solely on like
philosophy like i was thinking about i'm
gonna do a book on i wanted to call it
uh like something like unveil the maya
like um
basically like uh removing the the veil
of illusion
and uh when i talked to him we we talked
about like five or six
different books and we arrived
at doing this book on breathing and
one of the things i thought was like
well this is going to be the easiest
book because
i've done so much work with it and when
you've when you've spent a lot of time
with something and you've taught
something for a really long time and i
think that's
another thing that i feel really
grateful about
before writing the book is that i spent
so much time teaching it
that it uh that i knew exactly
how the whole thing was going to come
together before i even put
pen to paper yeah
what do most people have wrong about the
breath what do they think it
can or can't do that it can't or can
uh i mean that depends on who you're
talking to or who you're asking like if
you're asking a yogi
almost all yogis know pranayama like if
you're
if you've been practicing yoga for more
than six months you've at least
heard of pranayama or done some sort of
breath work
i think what they mostly get wrong is
they don't know why that they're doing
that it's like um it's like
i mean i i could also say that it's
probably true of a lot of people that
practice the physical
awesomeness stuff they don't understand
what's the purpose of triangle pose
they just do it because the teacher says
to do it so if you go down
and you start doing a practice like one
of the classic ones is called naughty
shoulder nah which
is uh alternate nostril breathing it's
really to balance you know and then
they'll explain this it's to balance
your eda
and your pingala energies but
like what does that mean right so i i
remember the first time i did it was in
in my my 200 hour teacher training
and i'm a very like kind of scientific
kind of very literal
i want facts and evidence and i want
things to be cited that's why there's
citations in my book you know like
reference
i want to understand where this is
coming from
why we're doing it what's the benefit
and then and this practice of alternate
nostril breathing you know
like you inhale through the left nostril
then you exhale through the right inhale
to the right
exhale to the left you're switching back
and forth but i know
once you go past the septum it just goes
right into the paranasal side the
perineal cavity in the sinuses and and
then uh down the trachea into the lungs
like it's
it's it just goes together and then it's
one
and so i didn't understand how there is
benefit or the physiological benefits
and there actually is there is there is
there is a lot that has to do with right
and left uh hemispheres with actually
balancing those energies but now i
understand
what those energies represent there's uh
there's has to do with um decreasing
the amount of breath so breath
regulation so you actually are breathing
less and what that breathing less does
as far as
uh stimulating the parasympathetic
nervous system and
increasing dorsal bagel complex tone and
and slowing the heart rate and just
bringing you down into like a deeper
state
and so and i also know how i could take
that practice and change it now
and that's the other thing is like
you're kind of given with with
traditional yoga you're given these
practices and it's like here's this
practice in the box
and you got to keep it in the box and
you can't really mess with it you just
got to do it exactly like this
and then here's this other practice and
these don't really go together
and then do this and it's like okay now
we do bastarica which is like a fast
breathing practice and i don't think i
was ever taught why i would want to do
bastrika
or or a lot of them and
even if you go and you start studying
like the older the older texts and talk
about pranayama the
the information that you're gonna get
seems pretty
pretty like out there and and
for me as as a spiritual yoga yogi to
say that like out there it's like if you
practice this in the way of the master
exactly as taught which is not
referenced in there
because you're supposed to learn
everything directly from your guru
people that are old will be young
you're like oh well that sounds pretty
good right and
it's just like um or or the other thing
that you get is this
this breathing practice if i if i look
online and i go what does this breathing
practice do and
i find somebody's website that wrote up
about it i want to see like 100
different things that this one breath
practice does and it's like does it
really do all those things
what does it do the most effective and
and why does it do those things
and so when i when um
i think as far as what people get wrong
with the breath it's not understanding
the potential
and then not understanding what the
breath that they're doing actually does
what are the principles of good
breathing then
what the foundational principles of it
like if you want to talk about just like
daily breathing like how should i
breathe
normally uh
well i think i think at this point most
people know
always breathe through your nose always
the in the the nose is a filtration
system it humidifies and it down
regulates the amount of air that we
breathe
uh it's funny because like now in kobe
time and talking about everyone wearing
masks and watching
especially in um my
my once home country i haven't lived
there in a really long time but
my home country of the states the good
old america
where people are like it's my god-given
right to breathe and i can't breathe if
i wear a mask and all and
i don't know i did a racist country
accent there
anything against people that are from
the country or the midwest but
yeah like the fact that you can't
breathe with a mask or that wearing a
mask
is is bad it's actually one of the
things that we
the benefits or the reasons why we want
to breathe less is to increase carbon
dioxide
to increase our co2 why would you want
that
well the effects that co2 has on the
body first of all
we so if i breathe right the one of the
common misconceptions
that people have is like if if i breathe
a lot if i breathe really fast i get
more oxygen
right if you heard that before i breathe
more you get more oxygen
have you ever put your finger in like a
an spo2 monitor
uh so spo2 monitors you probably have at
some point
they just put it like a little thing on
your finger it measures your
your blood oxygen saturation and it says
oh it's
like 97 to 99 generally
most people aren't below 95 and
and the majority of the air that you
breathe out or the majority of the
oxygen
that you take in you breathe the
majority of it out so you're not even
utilizing
most of the oxygen that you take in and
it's not
at a hundred percent usually because
there is some sort of
uh there's there's a chemical or there's
a there's a
an exchange between the oxygen the
carbon dioxide on the cellular level
so that's always happening
if i breathe more what happens is i
start to change my ph so i i have
by breathing more i'm not actually
getting more oxygen i'm breathing off
more carbon
dioxide so that's that breathing more is
going to affect my sympathetic nervous
system we see this in hrv heart rate
variability
so we know as i inhale i stimulate the
synthetic nervous
system and the heart speeds up and it
becomes more regular as i exhale
simulate the parasympathetic nervous
system the heart slows down
and it becomes more varied or irregular
which is which is a good thing the more
you i'm sure studied a bit into hrv
so so we know that we know just through
that as as one of the many things that
the
breath affects the nervous system so if
i breathe more i breathe faster
i get more sympathetic the other thing
is i breathe off
more carbon dioxide and so that changes
my blood
chemistry so i actually become more
alkalinic which we're like oh i want to
be alkalinic and i mean we could talk
about that i do
i do discuss that why you actually don't
want to be alkalinic through breathing
but sometimes you do i lose the carbon
dioxide
and the other thing that happens is the
oxygen
bond to the hemoglobin becomes uh
becomes much stronger so when i breathe
in we have the part the atmospheric
pressure that's in the lungs and that
kind of helps
push it onto the hemoglobin also also
the hemoglobin
it it's a different shape when it lets
go so
then it attaches the oxygen molecules
attached to the red blood cells and it
kind of like locks on there and then it
goes
well there's a system that tells it to
release and that system is is described
through the bore effect which uh
was you've heard of the bore effect
before in your board
in my book yeah okay so the bohr effect
basically basically states that
that um by increasing carbon dioxide
and and um decreasing ph
which is makes it more acidic that you
uh decrease the affinity or the
attraction of
oxygen to hemoglobin and so that allows
the oxygen and this is on on the in the
in this
tissues in the cellular in the cells
this allows the
oxygen to be released from the red blood
cells and go into the cells and so then
you have that exchange between
between oxygen and carbon dioxide right
so with without that
we don't really get the oxygen into the
body so we need that carbon dioxide
we also breathe we take our breaths
based on how much
how much carbon dioxide that we have in
in our body
so this is uh there's there's several
different breathing ways but one of the
ways is
is in the in the aortic arch it kind of
measures that and we have also in the
brain to which that measures oxygen but
we have
it measuring like how much carbon
dioxide so if um
my levels of carbon dioxide get high
then my body says breathe if they're low
it says don't breathe it's one of the
reasons why a wim hof method works how
it does
you breathe really fast you become you
don't you don't increase your oxygen
levels in fact you're you're doing the
opposite
by breathing fast you don't get the
exchange of oxygen on onto the
into the cells and one of the ways that
you can just test that real quick is to
hyperventilate and then
feel lightheaded and dizzy well the
reason why you feel lightheaded and
dizzy is one that you change the ph
it's not that you have more oxygen
because you know if you put on like a
hundred percent
oxygen you actually think clearer not
less you don't go
dizzy but then also you continue to do
that then you
because you're not getting the oxygen to
the tissues at the extremities you start
to have what's called cardio
uh carpal pedal spasms carpal hands
pedal feet
where you start to do this this
posturing stuff if you re
you see it like i was a paramedic for
eight years and people that
have panic attacks and hyperventilate
they're like this and then
if you do long long breathing like more
controlled you'll feel your face get
numb your belly get numb well all these
are
our effects of having low carbon dioxide
you become
hypocapnic or car deficient
in carbon dioxide well so when you do
whim hof breathing you do this
rapid fast breathing you become um
hypocapnic and and so then you're able
to hold the breath for a really
long time because those co2 levels have
to rise
back up to get to the point where you
want to take a breath again and that's
why you're able to do this and and you
hold on the exhale
which gives you the advantage of of
using up more oxygen so then once you
start using up the oxygen you're holding
the breath
your co2 levels come back up the oxygen
levels go
down and and now you this is where you
start getting into increasing like
athletic performance and all the other
benefits that come
from breathing less and and so then your
body
said we we make about two million to two
and a half million red blood cells
every second and also we lose about two
to two and a half million red blood
cells every second and those red blood
cells live for about three to four
months
each and it's a demand system so the
body's always trying to
mean it's always trying to do what it
needs to do to do what it needs to do
right this is this is like we want it we
want to give the bot the body wants to
give you what you need
but if you sit on the couch and you over
breathe all the time
when you get up and you try to run what
your body did was when those red blood
cells died it said well
you know be because we're over breathing
um
the the oxygen is staying on the red
blood cells and it's coming back to the
lungs
and so they're coming back with oxygen
so we don't really need that we have too
many red blood cells
those take energy to make and we're
making two million every second
so let's make less and then then you go
to run and you let the
then you're like [ __ ] i'm so winded uh
but if you breathe less even if you just
like so if you do cardio that
you are working towards the upper end of
your cardio respiratory limit
your heart is beating fast your
metabolisms increase even though you're
breathing
faster you're using more oxygen than
what you have and so the body goes oh
we need we need to we need to make more
red blood cells so that we can carry
more
the analogy that i i use there's a lot
of really good analogies but it's like
if you if you go you've been on the tube
before
so people that aren't aren't uh aren't
londoners or whatever are familiar with
the tube or the subway or the
underground or whatever
some sort of underground system
or like in china you see all these
people or japan i think it's japan all
these people like
pressing in trying to get as many people
into
one train car as possible well this is
this is
this is what we're trying to do when we
don't have a lot of red blood cells
right we pack those they can only be
packed full
and so if you if if you try to breathe
more to pack those more it's not it's
not going to do anything
and we already know that breathing more
is in fact actually when we breathe more
we're not allowing those
those passengers to get off so it's like
they do the whole circuit and they come
back and there's still people on there
right but what we need to do is we need
to add more train cars
and we need to be more efficient about
getting those people off of the cars
and so that's what adding more red blood
cells does it adds more train cars to
the system so that they're able to get
more oxygen on there and then by
breathing less and getting carbon
dioxide levels up and
and being more uh acidic in the blood
we're able
to get the oxygen off quicker and more
efficient
and so this helps with the efficiency of
breathing
one um i think a really good analogy
with with breath is understanding
kind of the same thing with diet so we
think oh this is how much i need to
breathe i'm breathing on demand
right and if you're someone that over
breathes
right that's what you need to breathe
you're just or especially if you're
breathing through the mouth
and and mouth breathers i mean other
than it just
it's um you know it's a sign of of of uh
unintelligence but also halitosis
and and all kinds of other things that
come up but if you're if you're
breathing through the mouth
you're breathing more than what you need
to immediately already
so you're breathing too much so it's um
it's like if you are if you eat too much
if you eat 12 000
calories a day and that's what you're
used to eating you're gonna put on a lot
of weight
and your body is going to need those
calories
because of the excess weight and all
those things and so you think that you
need to eat more and it becomes a cycle
and then as soon as you go on a diet
then your body goes oh
first part when you go on a diet you go
oh i'm starving i'm hungry
and and this is what air hunger is this
is what holding the breath does we
we are we're basically
pushing our co2 tolerance right our our
tolerance to how much carbon dioxide can
we have on the system
well if our tolerance is really low
we're going to breathe really fast if
we're able to build that tolerance
up we start to breathe slower so it's
like you know so i go on a diet i start
to eat less
i lose weight then my body adjusts to
that new weight it adjusts to the new
cal
caloric intake and then i'm healthier
and
i have a new normal so when it comes
like breathing like first off
is just to be conscious of how much
you're breathing like breathe
less i know there's a long way to get to
like one question but breathe less
breathe through your nose is the first
one it's it's already it's already gonna
to down regulate how much you're
breathing breathe slower when you could
think about it
and and if you can like periodically
hold a breath or do practices
where you have breath holding if you're
like someone like me that you want to
increase your athletic performance
really working into doing long breath
holds will
will help to increase your i mean
there's there's a whole
there's a whole like formula of all the
things you need to do to increase your
athletic performance through breathing
but
you increase your vital capacity how
much oxygen the
the lungs could hold you increase your
respiratory strength
just like any muscle when the muscle is
stronger it has to work less hard so if
you increase the the strength of your
respiratory muscles
through doing things i think we'll do
like a practice of how to increase
respiratory strength
so you increase the strength of your
diaphragm your your
your corset muscles like all your core
muscles your intercostal muscles
they're stronger so that means they work
less they they don't have to use as much
energy to do
to do the job so when you go out and
running those are muscles that aren't
having to work as hard so that means
they're not using as much
much oxygen uh you decrease your
you increase your co2 tolerance that
means you can get carbon dioxide levels
up higher so when you are running you
don't feel or whatever you're doing you
don't feel the need to breathe as
heavy um and then you're also
because you're increasing that you're
also through like the bore effect you're
getting
more oxygen into the cell so that's like
like
the real quick quick like uh quick and
dirty way to do that so breathing less
whenever you can whenever you can think
about it doing a breath practice that
focuses around breathing less
that doesn't mean the whole breast
practice is about breathing less like my
my athletic performance breath practice
there's a heat building part of it where
i do a lot of fast breathing when i or i
do
like something like wim hof work i do
some rapid
breath where i'm really working my
respiratory muscles
really strong and then um and then i
hold on and exhale then hold on an
inhale or there's different advantages
to holding on exhales compared to
holding on inhales and they're both good
so i do both
you know one works more towards co2
tolerance one
um works more towards lowering
lowering spo2 right so you kind of need
both of those you want both of those
the other the other thing is breathing
efficiently so
if i were to ask you right now take a
deep breath
take a deep deep inhale inhale deeper
inhale deeper inhale deeper
all right so note notice that thing what
just happened when you really started to
do it again
breathe and feel your lungs as full as
they get
as full did it do and if you're
listening to this also at home
so if you notice did you see your
shoulders went up like this
right so that is that is essentially
inefficient breathing
when we are filling the lungs we're
looking for space well as the lungs go
out the lungs there's there's a little
space
so the way the diaphragm works it's kind
of like uh it's
it like an m you know it's not so much
like a
an upside down u but it's more like an m
the the top of the diaphragm is
connected
and the way that this the central tendon
is is connected to the mediastinum which
is at the bottom of the heart
so this does move a little bit but if it
were to move
uh down as as much as the rest of the
diaphragm did it would cause some trauma
to the heart the heart would be going
like this every time you
you started running or taking a deep
breath so it doesn't want to do that
it's
the side of the diaphragm pulls down and
then the lungs as they fill up well they
can only go out so much
and then where they want to go is
actually down and they don't
go down into the core as we expand the
belly what expanding the belly does
is it allows the ribcage the bottom ribs
to open up outwards like this and then
the intercostals open
this way so we want the intercostals to
open downward like this so that we could
get into
this place where the lungs go into which
is called this the sub
subcostal recess little space if you
look at it
at an x-ray of the lungs when
you see like a little black area in the
pleural cavity right between the the
diaphragm and the ribs
so this the upper cavity so you see that
you want the lungs to be able to move
down into that and as you move the lungs
out
or the ribs out and down you open up
that space which opens up your vital
capacity
which is how much air you can put into
your lungs so you basically
with breathing with deep breaths you're
trying to open up as much as you can
well so that happens by breathing down
if i breathe up like
this there's not so much space and now i
start moving
into this platysmas area these muscles
here
and i'm like coming up there's and i'm
lifting my shoulders up well
as i lift up my shoulders this makes
that this pulls everything else up
and it also deflates the chest
so i'm not able to move it also takes a
whole lot longer
so when you when you breathe when you
take a deep breath you want to imagine
like you have a rubber band
right around the center of your ribs so
the middle part of your ribs so as you
inhale instead of inhaling up or down
you want to think of expanding it out in
in 360 degrees
so try that same breath really deep but
this time try to expand just in the
middle so you just inhale
and keep the shoulders where they are
and feel how fast and full you can feel
the breath
you feel that like immediately your
lungs are so much fuller and there was
way less effort right did you feel that
way less effort you're completely full
you couldn't expand it
and you might actually feel like you
could go even more
so this is like this is how we should be
breathing all the time and when we're
when we're doing something heavy where
we have heavy breathing
we need to be aware of like if i'm
running or something like this i don't
want to be
i don't want to be breathing or if i'm
doing something that's you know uh
if you do like jiu jitsu or anything
that really makes you
breathe super heavy and super hard when
i when i watch i mean this is something
i could go to
just the ufc and train ufc fighters and
immediately improve their performance
just by when they're when they're
working when you see them breathing
up into their chest like this or you
know they're breathing through their
mouth because they're trying to get more
oxygen well if if they had more red
blood cells they wouldn't need to
breathe in the mouth another thing is
when you're doing physical activity
always breathe your nose
right and and and let that so if you
can't do what you're doing if you can't
run faster breathing through your nose
run slower
right get that part up first and then
and then you'll be able to increase your
performance so much more and there's a
lot of studies
with runners and olympians that change
their their training practices breathing
through the nose and they increase their
time i mean
by by a small amount but if when you're
at an olympic level to increase your
time by anything
is huge like you think like between
first place and fifth place is less than
a second
right it's uh it's between being on the
platform or
or not or the podium yeah
how much can doing a practice
of between 10 and 20 minutes a day how
much
can that affect something a habit that
we're going to do for the rest of the
23 hours and 40 minutes every day
i can't one thing i'm interested in is
looking at
something that is is it habituated is it
necessary do we have conscious control
over it
how much of it is part of the is it
autonomous system and how much of it is
part of
like what i'm trying to work out is can
we undo the good work
during a breath practice of 10 or 20
minutes by not being conscious of it
throughout the day
and obviously we're doing stuff i can't
spend my whole day thinking about
breathing
well the one part you should think about
is breathing through the nose
right you should spend the if you notice
you're breathing through the mouth
throughout the day you should be like oh
or if you take if you yawn like this if
i yawn for whatever reason i hold my
breath
well coming into this it because if i
yawn i took i took a deep breath it's a
it's a minor
over breathing a minor little bit of
over breathing
and now i have i just inflated my my
lungs
a normal breath is is on average is
about a half a liter
a full breath is on average about for
for a man is about five and a half to
six and a half liters
so you know you just that you have
residual volume and stuff that you say
you're
you're actually probably breathing about
three liters with a deep breath
uh compared to the half of liter so
you're breathing like six
seven times more than what you need to
so already like that one deep breath i'm
like okay so i just i just
took like my breath all the breaths i
need for this entire
minute so i'm gonna hold my breath right
now like that's how i think about it
like as far as like doing the practice
in the morning this really gets down to
why you're doing the practice or where
you're doing the practice for because
you're going to change like for athletic
performance if you want to increase
athletic performance
15 minutes 20 minutes a day is not going
to do it it's the same thing like if you
want to increase long distance running
running for 5-10 minutes a day is not
going to increase your long-distance
running or
or any sports when it comes to
athleticism you need to move
more or do more uh with um
and then also there's something called
uh like splenic contraction so when you
are in a place of of oxygen
deficiency for so for a certain
period of time which is it change it's
different for everybody but roughly
about 15 minutes
it's like when you're working out or
you're running you get that second wind
about after like 15 minutes or why
people warm up
and when you do like these like crazy
warm-ups it's to get that splenic
contraction so the spleen which holds
red blood cells
contracts like this and it squirts out a
bunch more red blood cells into your
system so then you have more red blood
cells so you can do
more the body is pretty smart like this
so
it's already thinking ahead so it's
another way to become more polysynthetic
but you need you need to be able if
you're doing this regularly and you're
constantly working the spleen the spleen
is going to get used to contracting
more because it's it doesn't necessarily
empty itself it gives maybe a little bit
you know it doesn't want to give
everything all at once but if you
work into to lots of retentions like
that
into best practice you're going to get
more of that and it's going to it's why
if you do a breath practice
your like how it how i do
my practice i i normally start with two
minutes out of retention two minutes
into retention
and then two minutes 230 out of
retention 230 inner retention so it's
just like exhale hold the breath take an
inhale
hold the breath and the last one three
minutes out of retention three
exhale hold for three minutes inhale
hold for three minutes the third one
that i do is easier than usual the first
one
and that's because your body is is
getting those extra red blood cells
through that spleen and contraction so
if you're looking like that
15 to 20 minutes isn't going to really
increase it but doing this kind of
practice every day just like any
any kind of uh workout is going to
increase everything else
and as far as like the other aspects of
like um
you know if if i wanted to do something
to be more calm or relaxed
i'm going to feel the the effects
immediately afterwards
i'm not going to i'm not going to feel
it necessarily all the way throughout
the day because as soon as something
else
comes in to to change my nervous system
right i'm going to feel those effects of
the nervous system or if i do a practice
that
that like in the morning let's say i do
like an energizing practice like a
wake-up practice and i'm doing a lot of
a lot of things that really work into
the sympathetic nervous system i'm going
to feel really energized for a bit but
as soon as
that's going to wear off it's like
having a coffee right coffee only lasts
so long
the good you could essentially get the
same effects with that
so it's not really going to change this
the
autonomy of your life but it's it's a
tool
for what you need depending on what
you're doing like i said if you're doing
like an
uh 30 or 40 minutes of
of something to increase your vo2 max
like that kind of stuff you will see
those effects anytime that you
need to do anything that increases your
demand for
cardio yeah do you have any other
triggers that you use throughout the day
so you mentioned there that if you yawn
you hold your breath are there any other
triggers that people can use to ensure
that they're breathing correctly through
the normal day-to-day existence
uh other other kind of
not not not so much like when i when i
think about it i just
try to breathe slower doing a breath
practice where
you're even if you're doing 15 or 20
minutes a day like you don't have to be
a psycho like me and do 45 minutes to an
hour every single day
but but just doing something like that
is
especially if you do it in the morning
is going to start your day with
at least that mindfulness around the
breath so that awareness around the
breath and the way that i talk about the
breath like um
there's a lot of people out there with
with
you know their their kind of bio hacking
thing and saying this fixes all that and
the breath doesn't fix
anything it's that's it's like
anything it's like anything else like uh
we have
these these different aspects of health
right diet fitness sleep
stress good stress or bad stress and
breathing and so if we don't have
uh if we don't um have proper diet or we
bad we feel it through everything else
and if we don't sleep well we wake up we
feel
the same same thing with the breath so
we got it the breath is going to affect
everything on
on how we use it but it's more of
more of a tool so it's like a if i
breathe and i'm doing a practice that's
maybe really about balancing and
centering my mind balancing my nervous
system
good practice for this is box breathing
or square breathing where you inhale
hold exhale hold for like the same
amount of time there's been research
around
hrv with this how it shows to balance
the nervous system
so practice like this is good to put you
in a mindset
where you are more rational and more
clear
or more more balanced less um
less reactive but if it like
you know breathing can fix your
relationships if you're in the right
place
to fix your relationships but breathing
can't fix your relationship
you know you know what i'm saying it's
like so it can kind of act as a tool to
put you in a more
conscious mindset or to bring you out of
out of the sympathetic tone that's
triggering
whatever it is or if you are just
feeling super lazy and lethargic
sometimes like if i'm just
if uh i'm wanting to do something and
i'm i'm on the couch and i don't feel
like getting off the couch
i'll do a breath practice that'll
increase sometime i'll do some some
kabbalah bots here bostrica where i'm
like
just really fast in and out to the nose
pumping my breath and then maybe i'll
hold at the end because anytime i do
fast breathing i usually add in some
breath hold after that
but that brought me into my sympathetic
nervous system i'm in a safe place so i
talked about this the polybagel theory
in the book
you know sympathetic nervous system
doesn't always mean fight or flight it's
also
like mobility so i'm i'm in i feel i'm
in a safe place synthetic nervous system
and now it's like all right let's go
and all right i just motivated myself to
do whatever that is but
yeah so it's like the breath acts as a
tool
to help fix the areas of your life like
breathing is amazing for sleep it's
amazing to do
like i'll do breath practices if i'm
going to sleep but
if i drink coffee after like two or
three o'clock in the afternoon
if i'm stressed one of the things that
breathing can do is it could help
help with my mind with my thoughts and
letting go of all those things uh
so if i my mind is is really busy the
breathing could help with that but if
but if i'm yeah if i've just done a lot
of coffee or
i'm on on my computer until late at
night and i i have all this blue light
and stuff like these
different these different things are
going to affect my sleep yeah breathing
is going to help but it's not going to
solve the problem i have to go in
and fix those other aspects to help
improve might and help improve that it's
one it's one thing so breath is a tool
it's not it's not a cure-all
i suppose it's the same as talking about
will
exercise make me fit outside of exercise
you go well
there is a component of that you need to
train in the gym but also
you should try and get a little bit of
movement in throughout your day it's
like
do i need to eat well all the time it's
like well the more that you can eat well
the better
you need to have your square meals being
good but if you keep snacking in between
those
i.e good diet bad diet the that's also
going to have an effect on you
if you sleep well once a week and then
for the other nights of the week you
don't sleep so good
so yeah it makes sense that you have a
focused period on the breath which is
your practice and then you're cognizant
of it throughout the day and you're
trying to
instantiate those good habits as best
you can that does that does make sense
one of the things that i found
interesting was energetic locks
can you explain how that works so the
energetic locks
in yoga we call these bandas and this is
a
what i what i really like i hope as
being a non-yogi is like the stuff
made sense to you because i really try
to write it for non-yogi's but still
also appeal to because i am a yogi
in every sense of the term so still
still
appeal to what those things do uh
so a banda is an energetic lock it's
kind of from this old
ancient school of yoga i do talk quite a
bit
into it there's there's essential
there's locks like you could say there's
locks everywhere
but i talk about the three major locks
which is mulabanda the root lock
udiana bunda which is the the naval lock
and then
jalan jalendar abunda which is the
throat lock
in like practices like physical practice
like ashitanga you
hear a lot of uh mool abundant stuff
essentially it's like it's a contraction
each one of them is a contraction of a
different muscle
they do different things and the idea is
to
regulate the energetic flow and i think
with like
one one thing that people get really
confused on or
or don't understand is like what is
energy
that's that's like a you know you could
talk to
if you if you talk to a structural
engineer
about what energy is or you talk to a
an electrician about what energy is or
if you talk to like a spiritual guru
about what what energy
is they'll give you different answers i
mean
um it's what does it mean to you then
what does it mean in your
it's not that what it means to me it's
it has a lot of different definitions
right so you have thermal energy you
have you have
electrical energy you have kinetic
energy
uh you have so like the nervous system
as we move like
this this movement that we have is is
energy what tells my
my muscles to fire is is an electrical
impulse that happens through a sodium
potassium pump on the cellular level
that sends
a signal up or down from the brain
depending on efferent or afferent nerves
and then we have movement
so this is very much the western sense
of what we feel energy is in our body
right we have thermal energy obviously
like as is we
we produce heat uh i'm i'm in bali it's
quite hot right now and
i'm talking with my ac off and i'm
feeling
that my body heat as i i sweat up my
shirt
uh but yeah so there's a you know that's
that's another
type of energy and then when we get into
yoga we we
don't really know what we're saying when
we say energy and we talk about like
how the energy moves through the body
and so this was like the
the yoga we have
the the yoga yoga is quite old you know
it's thousands of years old and they
didn't have the tools to see
how myelinated and unmyelinated nerves
work or or how the signal transforms or
anything like that
but they they mapped out before they
even knew what nerves are they mapped
out these things called nadis which is
how
energy flows through the body and if you
if you uh
you'll feel it like if you hit your
funny bone or if you get a
kink you ever had like a kink in your
back and you feel it in your hand
right so that like the yogi's maybe
understood that is oh here's like an
energetic thing or
or just your level of energy how much
how much um energy you know what i'm
saying like
you're like your energetic levels i was
like to get out and do stuff or if
you're low on energy you don't want to
do something
so this is all things that we refer to
as energy and and
on a scientist on the western side i see
this as sympathetic parasympathetic
right what what is producing this level
of energy
well the yogis had a different map or
different system of energy
but it's the same thing they just they
just describe it different
and and one of the things that i i love
and and i really tried to do
in this book was to show how these two
actually it's four or five systems
depending on how you you're looking at
it but how these systems intertwine
because if we're talking about energy
it's all the same thing and we realize
it's it's all the same thing it's
it's my energy is essentially your inner
like as far as you're concerned as a
subjective experiencer
it's your interaction with the world and
how you move through it
that's that's your energy or how outer
things
affect you right so cold affects you
that's
an energetic thing heat affects you
that's an energetic thing
emotions affect you right that's an
energetic thing if someone
if someone you don't know just comes by
and gives you the bird or
or in london the the reverse peace
fingers
yeah i mean it's like california be like
peace right and then like
like oh i'm always like peace please
stop
and then they're like oh why why you
should why are you doing that to me i'm
like oh
peace brother like no no no that's like
this yeah
but you know that's that's felt with
energy we actually
feel that or if you go into a room and
somebody
you immediately feel someone's like good
energy or dark energy
and this is something that we have been
programmed from
from an evolutionary standpoint to keep
us safe is that person dangerous
or not dangerous well we use that word
energy
to say that this person has bad energy
meaning this person is dangerous
or this person has good energy meaning
this person's not dangerous maybe i want
to mate with this
person maybe i want to fight this person
right so we feel that
well the yogis did a great job of
mapping these types of energies out and
how they
they manifest in us and how they on
maybe an emotional level so when i start
thinking about the energetics
of of yoga i think of like more how are
these affecting
the energy emotional energetics of my
life
and how do i bring balance about this
and because i
i know and i understand that
how through the western system energy
and how you know emotions are
essentially just hormones and
neurotransmitters
and they're affected through the
sympathetic and parasympathetic nervous
system
right so our feelings our imbalances
like
if i have relation relationship problems
will you ever have a relationship
problem with someone you don't really
care about
yes yeah you don't it doesn't really
affect you
so much right you don't have those those
emotional imbalance even though you have
a relationship problem you're like
well again this relationship's over you
know right but
if you have a relationship problem
something you care a lot about they
affect you really deeply
even though they're both relationship
problems so it's but we're trying to
it's the the hormones that are that are
released and the neurotransmitters are
released that make us feel that way
which is so i know well
i know that through the breath if i
inhale then that's going to affect my
parasympathetic nervous system i know if
i exhale it's going to be
or sorry inhales when my sympathetic
exhale is going to be my parasympathetic
well also if i inhale this is going to
like i talk about the the yoga side of
the my
my rejossic energy so we're just like
energy
is the energy that goes out and expands
and dissipates
right it's it's uh we think of this
energy as the doing energy
right this is this is the energy that we
have and we think about the sympathetic
nervous system this is the moving energy
well what are the imbalances of of
always needing to do
always going after goals or whatever
like we burn out we get exhausted
we need balance in that and so now i'm
looking at something on an energetic
level of
okay well i don't just want more uh
energy to get going but
but where the imbalance here where i'm
burning myself
out right and i see that and it's like
okay well i want to bring balance into
this so maybe i need more tomosic energy
and thomas is things coming down
and contracting together consolidating
right but if i have too much of it then
i just i'm just like stuck
i'm stuck in my system or i'm wilting
away you know if you don't move you
atrophy
and this is this is the if we stop
moving it's not that we stop doing
anything we start dying and this is the
the energy of thomas and so we don't
want to be there
but if we're always moving then we burn
out so somewhere in there there's a
balance and this is
that balance is called saatva in yoga
and saatva is the energy of
being so rajas is doing
thomas is having it's there's good parts
of it
you know feeling warm safe comfortable
right these these things like
but if too much of that then you're like
you know the saying like
uh you never want to be too comfortable
because then you don't do anything
that's not really saying but it's based
off what they're saying that i remember
the saying is but yeah you know what i'm
saying
like there's like we don't want to be
too comfortable because
then we lose our rajas of doing so when
we find the balance of that we get into
being and and being only lasts so long
like any and we like why don't we always
just want to be in saatva well we do but
is that a possibility that's realistic
for people usually not
usually not usually we need to move or
we need to rest and so we're
tiptoeing like around this
we're always looking for homeostasis
until we find homeostasis and then we're
looking for something else
right what you know what i'm saying like
that's how the body works we're trying
to get balance as soon as your balance
the body goes okay we're let's there's
no growth in balance we need to
unbalance ourselves so we could grow
again and this is just the the yogis saw
this and they kind of so this is where
that system comes together
and so saatva to be the energy is
actually upward
i don't understand it but when you talk
about upward it's the upward flow of
energy is growth
and in saatva really it's our spiritual
growth or enlightenment enlightened
means to
shine light upon something that's dark
so that you understand it
you know so the illuminated the the the
name of my book is called the
illuminated breath
it's to basically remove the darkness
around the breast so that we understand
it
and that that's that's when you
understand it it's useful it becomes a
tool and you could you could work with
it
so this is like we see these energy
systems
as the same thing and when we see them
as the same thing and we just realize
that it's
yeah i use the the illustration of
looking at a map
if you draw a map well the map is
nothing it only represents something
that's real right if i
if i have a map of england well that's
a representation of england if i want to
go you're in manchester
newcastle or newcastle newcastle so if i
want to go up to newcastle from london
yeah i would follow well the m1 or
something i don't know the roads there
is that right correctly the a1 what it
turns into is about a mile away here
oh cool all right so so i would follow
the road system
but if i was to to build something
i would look at like city planning or
if you know or plumbing or something
like that or if i wanted to go hiking i
might look at a topography map
well they all just represent the same
thing they're just
different aspects of that thing and so
when i when i know
that what the map is representing and if
i know i move north i move north across
all maps
right but it's but what do what do i
need from that map
for it to be useful to me and that's why
the different systems are important
that's why understanding is important
moving is the breath so i need to i need
to move north
the breath is going to take me north how
do i
why do i need to move north am i going
north to come
see you am i going on a hike you know
it's like what what do i want to see
and so like we understand that i know
how the breath affects these different
things and this is something that
i laid out in the book to kind of make
it
it's it's really simple there's there's
one
venn diagram in there called the systems
of balance that shows
the autonomic nervous system the
polyvagal theory the naughties the
values and the gunas
and how that's affected through the
inhale or the exhale
and then um learn and then there's a
chaperone
on each of those that tells you what
that map actually represents
so you could be like okay well you know
i'm feeling
like my head's lost in the clouds i'm
just a dreamer well this is like
vienna value and that's what that map
represents
so it takes something that's really like
kind of fufu and gives you something
that that uh allows you to take a little
bit
more control of your life so that you
could
find balance if you need balance or if
you're like i'm
too stuck in the center how do i move
out of the center
right because that might be something
that you need as well the
final paragraph in your book is really
really beautiful i just wanted to read
it here
learning to breathe is like learning to
live the smallest details hold the most
significance
a single step in an epic adventure
carries with it all the subtleties of
experience that we have gained along the
way
the destination is just one more step in
the perpetual cycle of inhalations and
exhalations
each breath contains all the potential
of life and we can't hold either one
forever
maybe by learning to breathe we can
discover living we're guaranteed only
two
breaths in this life are first and our
last we can waste every breath
merely existing or we can use every
breath to create meaning and experience
the true miracle of living
sick way to finish your book man thanks
really good yeah uh spoiler alert
yeah exactly that's it that and then and
he dies at the end
he dies at the end um you were gonna
show us a breath practice
and maybe people who aren't driving or
operating heavy machinery could follow
along at home
right you could do you could be part of
this operating heavy machinery in fact
that's
that's the thing about the the breath
practice you could
pretty much do it anywhere right where
like um i this this sounds pretty bad
but i don't
like when i do my breath practice in the
morning i'm not like
i do a meditation practice i get up i
get out of my bed i have
i have this beautiful view of the jungle
i open up my curtains
i have a i have a seat at the foot of my
bed or it's elevated up and i sit there
and i do my 30 minutes of meditation
then i go downstairs and i prop myself
up on the couch
which is
right here and then i
look at the tv which is right there and
i do my my 45 minutes to an
hour athletic performance while i'm
watching the news
or catching up like is you know being in
bali i want to see what's going on in
the rest of the world
less now that trump's out of office but
it's still pretty interesting but also
america's season three is going to be so
boring now that he's gone he was the
only good character in it
yeah for sure i'm like i got kind of got
addicted to the crazy drama
sorry did you see that the the news
anchors had done a little campaign make
news boring again
it's crazy yeah and all of them are the
stephen colbert and
and all those guys are all talking about
like oh you know
i'm so excited for for boring stories
yeah but uh my point is i do
my practice while i'm while i'm watching
tv so it's not like something like you
have to like separate your life
from it if if um if you're someone that
commutes a lot
when actually this is something that
i've been doing for years
in in london because i i spent a lot of
time in london
when i go from one one stop to the next
stop
on the tube i hold my breath between
stops
so i'll do that like it doesn't matter
like if if there's like 18 or 20 stops
or whatever if i'm going like super far
usually it's only like four or five
but i and sometimes they're they're
pretty far in between but like i breathe
i i breathe when the doors are open and
when the door is closed i hold my breath
sometimes i yeah oh yeah trigger yeah so
so like that's like i do those those
kinds of things like you know when you
think about
opportunities to breathe consciously
your opportunities to
increase something that you you want to
work on i'm someone that's
very much into fitness and and
increasing like my fitness levels and
all that
so yeah so you can do
you can do this really most best
practices anywhere
uh i teach on this app called the aloe
moves and
they they want to do like something for
the plane and
they they said something they didn't
want using my programs there's a lot of
like touching your face and stuff which
is obviously not good with
coveted times as well but like the
naughty show to not practice
uh is a lot of that's that's really the
only one where you're touching your face
or if you're doing
brahmary where you're like and doing
shankara mudra
um anyways uh but yeah so it's like
yeah you've uh you do this press
practice anyway so getting into it so
we're gonna do
a really quick practice i'm actually
gonna teach you three
different breath practices which is kind
of fun
three different breath practices and
what we're doing the first two is like
level of energetics right so these these
are
all to increase respiratory strength uh
one the first one is going to help you
learn how to actively
or sorry passively relax your belly
which is something that we
another thing that we do that creates
inefficient breathing i didn't mention
is
especially if you're a fit guy or if you
if you like your six pack or whatever or
you just hold your gut in
all the time right if you if you're
constantly contracted to the core you're
not allowing your bottom ribs to release
and so you're basically
inefficient in breathing so um
so we're going to do is you're going to
inhale talk about those bondos the
the udiana banda which is the the naval
lock which is like
another way to think about it is like a
vacuum breath you pull the belly in and
up towards the spine now this isn't good
to do if you've drinking a lot of water
if you've just eaten or you need to go
the bathroom it's uncomfortable you can
still do it
but it's it's not as comfortable i like
to do these
all my athletic performance breathing uh
on a completely empty stomach so it's a
active forced exhale
and if you just actively force exhale
through the nose
and a passive inhale normally what we do
is we breathe is we do an
active inhale and a passive exhale so
this is
flipping it we're we're moving um
a little bit more air if we like i said
we're moving about 500 to mls now we're
moving about
700 800 to 1000 maybe
so a a little bit more not not a
dramatic amount and you kind of want to
go at the pace that you do so
i'm going to first just sit here and do
it and then i'll show you what my
stomach is doing
i'll pull up my shirt so you can kind of
see my stomach so it's the first one is
it's just exhale through the nose
passive inhale
yeah maybe clear the nose get the
boogies out
so it's
it takes practice to build up speed so
it's good to when you're starting it to
maybe go slowly maybe go
we'll do it at that speed my normal
speed is like
but the inhales you hear it the inhale
is passive so it looks
on this level it looks like this so
all right so that's the first one we're
going to do that one and and
here we'll we'll do these together i
won't count them we'll do it for
about actually yeah we'll do it for
about 20 seconds each i'll say
i'll say first practice kabal bhati and
i'll say second practice bastarika so ba
baba means skull shining breath not
going to get into why it means that
second practice it's in the book it
doesn't matter second practice is called
bastrika which is
billow's breath so billows like is
something that they used to have i don't
know you guys like fire things like you
did like this
and it goes in and out so this is a
force inhalation and a force exhalation
so as we talk about like the energetics
of breath or or how much it's affecting
the nervous system this is
more extreme it's like why are they
different well why do you do
jogging why do you do sprinting right
the one
one is more than the other so it's doing
the same thing but it's affecting it
more
and little difference with how it's
affecting respiratory control or your
dexterity over breathing which is also
something important that we haven't
talked about so much in this
and increasing the respiratory strength
on a forced inhale
and a forced exhale so here we're adding
the force inhale so this is
deeper first one we're moving like i
said between maybe 700 to 1000 now we're
moving from like
1200 to if you're really good at it to
maybe about 2 000 or
2500 ml remember average breath
is about about 500 mls
full breath full deep breath is about
three
to four thousand mls depending on how
efficient you are at breathing when you
get really efficient you take a full
breath
it's going to be four or once you get
your vital capacity up and the
full breath might be five or six
thousand mls stixx ferensen is
he's uh 11
and like a half liters he get hold his
breath for like 22 minutes
free diver guy awesome awesome breather
um but yeah so you could really increase
your capacity quite a bit so this one
it looks like this like
[Music]
notice my shoulders i'm not like this
it's
[Music]
so if you look at the belly now it looks
like this
[Music]
so
getting that force exhale it's harder to
do it standing up it's a little easier
to do it sitting down
so that's the second practice do that
one about 20 seconds so the first one
it'll look like this as we're building
it'll be like
we'll do a little slower so maybe like
this
[Music]
i'm going to bostrika be a little bit
more like this
[Music]
roughly about this pace and the last one
we're going to do is
on an outer retention so what what we're
doing in this one we're
decreasing our carbon dioxide so we
become that word
hypocapnic so once we decrease our
carbon dioxide we become hypocapnic
and then we're going to hold the breath
on the outer retention within yoga it's
called
container so it's uh it's basically
referring to the breath hold and this
one you uh
i did this as a kid so it's the it's
like udiana bunda
where you i try to make myself look like
skeletor or whatever like
suck my stomach in and try to be as
skinny as i i can see do this on a full
exhale empty out as much as you can out
of the lungs
then you're going to pull the belly in
as as deep as you can like you're trying
to glue the navel to the upper portion
of your spine
so you don't want to think just in you
want to think like
in and up right and this is it's uh
another way to do that is like you
exhale completely and then you inhale
but without inhaling through your mouth
so you're creating
inter abdominal pressure so you're
and that's going to suck the belly up
and then while holding the breath still
you're going to release
and and completely relax all the muscles
and so it's going to act like this
pumping when i'm down
uh sometimes like it sounds like a
slapping action like it's slapping my
my my stump so it's like so do this one
again
so i'll exhale i can't talk after i do
this so i'll just show you so
so that one is just in out
it's this one's a lot easier to do
sitting down as well i think
at least i always practice it sitting
now so i don't really practice it
standing up and it's also awkward to
like look at myself on the screen while
doing it
like what am i doing rather than feeling
like what's the reason
what what's the reason for the movement
of the stomach uh
upon the exhalation so
on the well first of all you can't
really do this breath on an inhalation
right you could try it but you're not
going to get as much movement but
really you're doing two things one it's
a outer retention breath hold
so you're on when you hold on out of
retention
your body uses oxygen a lot the
available oxygen a lot faster
right so you start to decrease spo2
faster before co2 tolerance comes up
because
you know we're that's what's causing us
to breathe it's not so much the oxygen
at a point the oxygen will be like oh
it's time to breathe
but for most of us it's we we're we're
on on a
carbonic drive so that that's co2
when i hold it on the inhale i'm the
i have a longer time i have more oxygen
in the lung so i have a longer time for
the
oxygen to come down and so the the the
co2 tolerance also has a longer time to
to build up we could hold our breath
much longer on an inhale than an exhale
because there's more available oxygen
there
so that's one of the advantages there's
less available oxygen so we decrease
oxygen faster
which helps with that the the body's
effect to want to make
more red blood cells so it's really
that's a really good advantage there
holding the breath on the exhale the
other thing what we're doing is this
practice is all about strengthening
respiratory
muscles really the deep respiratory
muscles in the diaphragm so i'm
really using the diaphragm because what
the diaphragm does is it's for
inhalation as i inhale it pulls down as
i'm doing this breath it's uh
i'm doing it against a greater
resistance because i i'm holding it
close and because
so that extra resistance as i pull the
navel in and up
helps to strengthen the diaphragm even
more and it's a muscle so
like all muscles it gets stronger when
you use it relaxing the belly
uh it allows me to go quicker because
we're not breathing so it's not
you could push it out but it's it's
better just to just to relax it in the
sense and it's much fat much faster so
we're trying to get
as many you know as many effective
uh it's called agni sar agnisar means
fire essence breath
agni is firing so this is centered
around the third chakra which is related
to firing that's a whole bunch of yoga
yoga stuff that we don't need to talk
about but yeah so anyway so
uh we're we're working in that and this
this whole practice is about increasing
respiratory strength that's the purpose
of this
i would i wouldn't do this by itself i
would do this
as part of a greater practice and
i have an intermediate sequence where
this is what
in the book i talk about the different
parts of the breast sequence this would
be like the
heat building sequence cool so we know
why we're doing it
which is really important if you don't
know why you're doing it why do it
right it's just like and that's
i have a clear intention and when i have
a clear intention i'm clear about the
goals that i wanted to do
and so if i know my goals and i know my
intention it helps me to find the tools
that i need to get there
and so this is one of those tools to get
there and that's that's we're just
building we're just building this growth
equation the equation for
for i don't know yeah so my my equation
for life how to grow intention
action purpose
let's do it all right so we're gonna do
it uh would
should i just sit here like this or do
you want to see the belly everyone's
okay okay there you go
all right everyone understands it and
this is recorded so just rewind it if
you forgot
all right so i'm going to do the
practice with you i will just
queue we'll do each one let me start a
little timer on my phone so i could just
see
so i can just see we'll do 20 seconds of
each
uh each one and move on to the next so
20 seconds kabalabati
or skull shining breath 20 seconds
pastrica
or billow's breath and then 20 seconds
agnisar which is the exhale hold
exhale so if you see me not eat if you
don't hear me breathing that means you
shouldn't be breathing
right if you and just i'm going to
breathe kind of a slower moderate
pace if you can't breathe as fast as me
breathe at your own pace that's really
like breathing is one of those things
you could 100
a approach at whatever level you're at
so
here we go three two one kabalabati
costa
inhale exhale completely
agnesar begin
inhale
exhale so that's uh
that's just like one round you know real
quick that took one minute
uh this would be something that's really
good to do for like five or ten minutes
right and then you work at your own pace
just 20 seconds of each
and you could already feel do you feel a
little bit more energized right
immediately that's a sympathetic nervous
system kicking in
and going all right you know we got some
energy to move it's a really great
practices
something you could do it's something
you do like between
sets as you're as you're getting going
from one thing or another or if you're
just like right before you're ready to
start running or
even on like yeah uh
like i said breathing is one of those
things we're always doing it we're
always doing
it and how you do it matters
all right what's the favor saying
how you do one thing is how you do
everything how do you breathe because
that's what you're doing the most of
you're not doing any one activity more
than that
not one that you can control anyways
dude
i love it thank you for today one of my
favorite things that i'll be taking away
is
um reframing the way that the
sympathetic and the parasympathetic
nervous system
work it's kind of like almost like the
sympathetic nervous system is being
demonized
now very much so in sort of common
common discussions around it but it's
got a usefulness
so so much so and i think it's not
without
without reason why the sympathetic
nervous system is demonized
most people are chronically in it and so
if i think if everybody was
chronically in their parasympathetic
nervous system if we lived in a society
where everyone was
so relaxed and they just like
uh you know we would demonize the
parasympathetic nervous system because
no one would be doing anything they'd
just be like oh everyone's just so lazy
and lethargic right
but because we are in this like this
to-do mode this rogers motive
we i always need to do something always
need to be productive
and one of the things that is even if
you're not doing something you're
thinking about doing something
and thinking the body like thinking
about doing something and doing
something affects the nervous system
basically the same way
but yeah it's it is definitely very
useful
and i'm glad i'm glad you brought that
up because i
i did try to spend quite a bit of time
in the book talking about the usefulness
of the of the sympathetic nervous system
and it's like a i don't know if you've
read any studies on stress
and the body's response to stress is is
significantly
different if it's viewed as a positive
thing versus
if it's viewed as a negative thing and
the the
the nervous system which is affected by
stress and and
kind of both ways how it it
its physiological response is very
different
based on whether we feel safe or unsafe
and that's that's a huge thing and
that's really important to understand
a big part of that is going to be
because of
what how people interpret the sensations
that are going through their body sam
harris
talks about this where he says imagine
that you felt
spontaneously the way that you do at the
end of a very heavy set in the gym or at
the end of doing a heavy cardio workout
you would think that you were dying it
would be awful you'd be terrified
and yet you elect to do that when you go
into the gym
so it shows us that it isn't about the
sensations it's about our judgments upon
them that's what marcus aurelius said
right
and um it's 100 i wonder whether
some people perhaps aren't allowing
themselves to lean into
that discomfort the same way that they
would do from the sympathetic nervous
system
because of the fear of it i've been told
that the flight and fight response
is bad for me that i need to be
parasympathetic one of the things
that i've relied on the most especially
over the last year when training
has been to remind myself that this is
why you're here
when you're doing something which is
challenging and worthwhile and it
becomes challenging
that's why you're here you're not here
for it to be easy you're here because
the discomfort is growth
that can be pushed too far but for the
most part i think people
undertrain rather than over train i
think that they probably over breathe
rather than under breathe
so the discomfort of feeling that uh
breath hunger
the discomfort of feeling the burn in
the gym the ache in the muscles
like that's why you're here it's a
feature not a bug
of this system and um yeah reframing it
that way i really hope that some people
have
have taken that away from it uh where
should people go they want to check out
the book they want to learn more about
you where do they go
so here's the book i just got this
yesterday you have
like so excited about it um yeah the
illuminated breath
by me uh
where you could buy books that's where
where you could get it so if you go on
amazon go on amazon you can get this if
you go to my website
dylanwarneryoga.com there's on the on
the top menu thing there's a link that
says the illuminated breath click on
that
and i have a ton of different links of
different places you can buy it so
that's really
for like if you're in the us or you're
the uk or somewhere else outside
i'm pretty sure it delivers it ships
everywhere
so i mean i'm here in bali i got it here
it's uh the launch date for the us
i think it starts delivering the 23rd of
february
i'm not sure when this is this is going
to come out
uh and i think the uk is like the 28th
or the 29th but uh
whatever day it is for you you should
just like go out and order it right now
so you're like the first one to get it
the link to pre-order will be in the
show notes below
and of course your instagram as well
where you share quite a lot of cool
stuff
yeah uh dylan warner yoga that's that's
uh just got a couple followers on there
um i feel really i'm really grateful for
for the followers that i do have you
know i i actually just really grateful
for this life that i have
you know it's um i
you know you just get lucky sometimes i
feel like i got super lucky in life
to land here but yeah uh check me out
there i
i just mostly posting handstands and arm
balances and other stuff that people
think is impossible but
if a 40 year old dude like me can do it
then uh anyone can do it
yeah and it's it to be to be i didn't
even start handstand until i was like 29
years old so it's it's never too late
brother i love it thank you very much
for today i hope that everyone's taking
a lot away from this
links to everything you've spoken about
your website illuminatedbreath and your
instagram
will be in the show notes below and if
anyone's got any feedback just
leave it in the comments or abuse dylan
in his dms
yeah yeah please i don't really answer
my dms because
i don't know sometimes sometimes i do it
depends it depends but if you get lucky
i'll answer you in there but if uh
yeah abuse abuse chris or don't abuse me
this is your this is your turn look man
thank you so much enjoy bali
ah thank you thank you uh really
appreciate you having me here
truly honored and uh lots of gratitude
thank you
you